la primera reacción ha sido del
presidente pedro que ha sido quien ha
fustigado duramente al congreso a la
fiscalía de la prensa los cuales los ha
responsabilizado de confabular en su
contra estas palabras han sido
rechazadas por la presidenta del
parlament o lady camones quien le exige
al mandatario peruano brindar todas las
facilidades facilidades a la fiscalía
para el cumplimiento de sus funciones
porque según ley de camón es el perú
necesita esclarecer los supuestos actos
de corrupción que habrían
realizado tanto el presidente pedro
castillo su familia y sus funcionarios
más cercanos mientras tanto algunos
legisladores como el derechista carlos
anderson consideran que el presidente
pedro castillo es consciente de que sus
días estarían contados